[Music]
that's a really wonderful question what
is the lhasa pian why should why do we
need it
of course many people think we don't
need it anymore
and I can sympathize with that reaction
when they look at the inward turning
character of much contemporary
philosophy especially written in English
but I think philosophy is immensely
important I think the search for the
large ideas about truth knowledge beauty
justice that is in the classical
philosophical tradition not only in the
West but also in the East is a terribly
important thing that said I think it was
misguided I am at the end of the day a
pragmatist and I don't think we're ever
going to find the big theories of truth
justice etc that are the classical
philosophers of sort but I think what
they've given us are all sorts of
wonderful tools for thinking about the
deepest and largest human questions
those questions are how should we try to
live and how should we try to live
together and the questions are connected
with one another now I want to suggest
that rather than trying to give some
definitive theory of the will answer
those questions what we should do is try
to think about our current state and the
problems that arise for human beings
living well living happily living
valuable in meaningful lives how at a
particular moment in time our moment in
time are they limited and how could we
get beyond those limits and philosophers
aren't in the business in my view of
trying to arm sort of add some sort of
knowledge to the knowledge that is given
by physicists and art critics and and
linguists and anthropologists etc etc
etc
the articles are in the business of
trying to fit all of that together so
that we have a picture of where people
stand at a particular moment in time
and how lives are problematic so that we
can be in a position to diagnose ways in
which we might go forward I said this is
a thoroughly pragmatist approach and it
is because it's not about perfection
it's a matter of improvement and
philosophers I think how are in the
business of trying to give us that
general picture of ourselves and our
place in the world and the kinds of
lives that we live that will enable us
to take the next steps in improving
things for ourselves and that means that
philosophy is a synthetic discipline
primarily it's something that draws from
lots and lots and lots of different
areas and draws from life as it exists
at a particular moment in time so every
age will always need its philosophers
and in the past we've had great
synthesizers we think of people like
Plato and Aristotle in the ancient West
we think of people I can't and Hegel in
the more recent West we think of people
like Confucius and Mencius and so on
these are all attempts seems to me to
find a big synthesis and that's what
philosophy is all about and that's what
it needs and that's what philosophers I
think should be trying to accomplish
[Music]